This is what I usually feel when it comes to things
in another
world.This is how I thought of being given the power of a hero by a gentle goddess and
being loved by the inhabitants of another world while going on
6 different adventures with a cute heroine
.  Is there anything else?
This is my case,
this is my adventure
.
ran
[Applause]
Are you
ready
?
All of the seeds are only rice,
oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
, just a star, was just a perfect laugh land
.  Applause
] de ciao was
[music] It
was a normal day
Breakfast with my family in the morning
Relegation to the archery club practice
Dinner at home
after the pros Net and reading
That's why I have to
sleep at home, so it's weird I'm
stuck in an event at any high school Don't
believe me if I say God No,
I'm going to have you go to another world from now on
I'm going to give you a sign that I agree
Suddenly say something like another world  I'm sorry
to hear that, but it's okay to hear that there's a funny story going
through.I sprayed this.
Look,
Tsukuyomi no Mikoto, one of the three whirlpool shrine maidens in Japanese mythology
.
I'm a human.Eh, when you say it,I've never had any relatives,but
it's a different
world.I heard that your parents made a contract with the goddess of the world
and came to Japan.
I understand the area around Noriko-nee-san's house that I can't sign a contract.
Let's dispose of it responsibly Hmm, it's
Takami, the traveler
[music]
This is the contract, is this letter
enough for
your family?  Let's eat as much power as we can
. Thank you.
If Tsukuyomi-sama says so, I
'll accept even a daring goddess
Oh, once again
[Music]
The power of 23 is pretty weak, right?
We're
in a big pinch So let's read stability and let's help
Wow,
really,
let's go
[music]
Yeah 0 where's the ugly
duckling That's why I cut off the cooling off and quickly
disappear from sight
Come on, which one do you choose?
I'll make sure you can understand the language, read and write
.
I don't know if I'll break up again If I want to
go to a large scale, it's
McDonald's
3 Sour
The goddess doesn't want to go on a violent act like
this Well, if it's Sei-dono, I'm sure he'll be fine even if he's this tall.
A
barren world in a country where magic power can't reach, and an extremely strong load was gathered on both magical power and body.
f
I
'm Spoon's wife, but I've used a lot of power in this update
.
In the name of
Yomi I hope to meet you again in the ring of souls that
grants freedom in a new world.  Mi-sama,
yes
[music] Get
down to the ground and
keep walking toward that high mountain
Bake Ya
Mikkaa No sound, no food,
3 days without drinking or eating I can barely move
Is it because it's a superhuman specification?
I've heard nothing but the sound of footsteps and the wind.
Who's standing in summer
Bach's rolopero 4
Other good things
Haaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaan
It's okay I have gentle and kind eyes
Wait a minute
[Music] It
's true that no one helped you In other
words, I'm on your side
I don't know which way to go to meet people
There's no Hume Nomura nearby
I'm in a barren wasteland called the end of the world A
[ __ ] woman really flew to the end of the world
Hey,
I'm Highland Many ema
My name is Makoto
Emma's village is near here
I'm on my way to the goddess Yamashin as a sacrifice to the gods.
The harvest
stopped, and the fog had subsided after the sacrifices were made
.
Please,
I have a good personality,
and I want to help you if possible.
Maybe it's mixed with the blood of the
customer, so I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Well,
actually,
if you don't mind at all, could you tell me?
Come on from the book, it's the day that becomes the core
of the flame, isn't it?
It's the core day of
Brid ah ah Deikiter
What should I do from here
If I imagine a bullet of fire and shoot it to the goal, it's an
image It's an
image from above
me It's
easy to
do Shin-sama, what is your current level?
Is
there such a thing as a level? [Music] What is it? I caught road mud by level measurement I'm sure it should be level 200 bier 300 whirl Please grab this hair Huh Huh There are so many levels
Epel match
Oh, if you'd like  Let's put together other magic
spells.
I'll do something about it I
could read the magic list and even put on my hair This
is the ability of that [ __ ] goddess.
A school that thinks about crossing and practices it
Brit
okay  No
matter
how you look at it, it's
a drug-
like strategy.
Rou
Okkun Ichigi 4 Gods are supposed to create a mirage in reincarnation It's
supposed to be a giant clam ability, but in the world I don't know what I'm
doing
dai
car
Uwaaaaaa
Tree
rules I have
a vision as a hobby
And black fog  Isn't it good
[music]
Good, good, good, good
This is the
ability Tsukuyomi-sama gave
me.
No, catcher
[music]
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
, who
are you?
Hasegawa What's wrong with that
swordtail?Ever
since you praised me for looking good on you before, this girl is
wonderful.Every sound is a virtue.
It's not good
I like studying, but I'm not
a
genius.
Is it no good? It
doesn't make sense o 5 Is he a visitor from another world
?
I joined the club
Spearhead Okay, thank you Hasegawa Please call me by my name, nook
Umi
But for now,
seniors, let's have a lot of fun during summer vacation
Oh
, I'm looking forward to it No,
this isn't solid
Because I was the
Hasegawa woman at that time
I'm sorry for making you play the car
number.The ability I received from Yomi-sama is that
I
can attach a hemispherical area to my resin
and give it characteristics and effects within it.
Thank
you for letting me know you so much Thank you I'll
use a little non-standard I
hit my eyes and say I don't have ak anymore
Please eat something else Even though it's a hallucination of the desires of the symbol, it makes me
feel uncomfortable
I apologize from the
bottom of my heart That's my ex-Poe,
a person
from another world.
Why don't you make a contract with
ah ah ah?
I'm interested in enduring Seidono's memories Definitely a good decision Language family My memories How far did you see What
secrets
me Oda  I don't think so, but
oh, my name
Thank you for your continued
support
.  Hey
lu It's a relationship that's practically close to a servant
Me It's not easy It's not easy I can't
wait to see what I'll
shake from now on
I want you to call me a samurai,
the cool beauty of your clothes.
Good good [music] car only my own thoughts me [music] good good good black clouds of disaster